thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
video
the atmosphere has been studied for
millennia some of the earliest examples
of writing contain references to the
weather and predicting and understanding
the weather was a key part of many
ancient religions particularly in
ancient babylonia for example but the
study of the atmosphere was always
limited by the fact that we humans are
trapped on the surface of the earth and
its atmosphere goes a fair bit higher so
when flight was made possible first by
balloons it was an exciting time for the
study of the atmosphere the first
successful human flight took place in
1783 in france via hot air balloon that
was quite quickly followed by another
flight in a balloon that was lifted via
lighter than air gas like for example
hydrogen and the brave people who took
part in these early experiments and
started exploring the skies via balloons
became known as aeronauts quite
literally air sailors and one particular
example of an aeronaut was henry coxwell
coxwell was an incredibly skilled
balloonist with dozens of successful
flights under his belt some of which
nearly killed him by the time that he
was asked to construct a huge new
balloon called the mammoth he was asked
to do this by a fascinating man called
james glacier glacier was the head of
the department of meteorology at the
royal observatory in greenwich london
but before that before being trapped
behind a desk glacier worked out in the
field he collected observations for the
british trigonometric survey and he
recognized that science was limited by
the data available so he tasked coxwell
with building the mammoth and training
up some meteorologists to take
observations of the atmosphere above the
surface of the earth
but one day one of the meteorologists
declined to ascend and so glacier seized
on the opportunity to get out from
behind his desk and get out taking
observations again in the field
well the sky now the atmosphere gets
thinner and colder the higher you get
this has been known for a long time it
was presumed that this meant the
atmosphere simply got colder and colder
until there's no air anymore and you
reach outer space but it turns out that
isn't true while the air density
decreases uniformly with altitude until
you reach space
temperature does not as coxwell and
glacier ascended in the mammoth on the
5th of september 1862
it eventually became clear that
something was very wrong
the balloon's rate of ascent was
controlled by the quantity of
lighter-than-air gas they used coal gas
contained within the balloon so you
could slow your rate of ascent by
venting some of that gas via a release
line
but as the balloon had ascended it had
twisted and the release line for venting
the gas had become twisted up in the
rigging such that
they couldn't use it the pair had no
control over their rate of ascent and
they were going up faster and faster and
faster
higher than anyone had in human history
so in this desperate situation
coxwell was forced
eight kilometers above the earth's
surface to climb out of the basket and
up into the rigging to try and free the
line but at this point the air around
the aeronauts is so thin that there's
just not enough oxygen in it so glacier
falls unconscious right up until this
point he's been taking measurements but
slumps against the basket and coxwell is
barely hanging in there and i mean that
literally because at this altitude it's
so cold that he loses all sensation in
his hands and they actually start to
turn black with frostbite so he's just
barely hanging on in the rigging and
eventually he manages to grab hold of
the release line and he jumps back down
into the basket but finds that his hands
are so cold that he can't pull on the
line he's only able to save his life and
glacier's life by taking the rope and
putting it in his teeth and then yanking
as hard as he can with his neck until he
hears some gas venting above
and at this point like
seconds from cheating death there's this
amazingly victorian exchange between the
pair and coxwell goes over to glacier
and he wakes him up cogswell says to
glacier do try to take temperature and
barometer observations do try glacier
replies i have been insensible to which
cogswell says you have and i too very
nearly glacier did start taking
measurements again but by the time he
did the bloom was already descending and
so data is missing from the very zenith
of their flight so we can only estimate
how high they actually went but likely
that maximum altitude achieved was
between nine and a half kilometers and
11 kilometers above the surface which is
unbelievably still an altitude record
for flight without assistance by
breathing apparatus had glacier remained
sensible to use his own word then he
would have made a shocking discovery
because if he'd been looking at his
instruments at that altitude as they
ascended while the air pressure would
have continued to fall the air
temperature would have stayed exactly
the same in fact eventually it would
have increased as they continued to
ascend that's because they'd entered the
stratosphere this is the second layer of
the earth's atmosphere with very
different dynamics to the layer that we
live in below called the troposphere
it's almost certain that coxwell and
glacier were the first humans to enter
this
alien ghostly section of the earth's
atmosphere but were simply
unprepared for the conditions they found
there so they made the briefest of
forays and then just slipped back down
through the clouds unaware of the
threshold they had crossed if glacier
had stayed conscious he would have made
a paradigm shifting discovery about the
earth's atmosphere that it was formed of
distinct layers but this instead fell to
the astoundingly named pair of leon
philippe tesserang de boer and richard
asman half a century later if you'd like
to learn more about that and the
surrounding history you should probably
pre-order my upcoming book firmament
link in the description on the
development of atmospheric science
scientific progress in all fields is
limited by technological factors we
couldn't take observations of the
atmosphere until the thermometer and the
barometer were invented we couldn't take
observations above the surface until
balloons were invented and without the
invention of breathing apparatus we
could barely scratch the stratosphere
improvements in balloon technology and
eventually liquid-fueled rockets enabled
us to map the entire atmosphere but at
the end of the day it required humans to
use that technology to use it in an
intelligent way and in some cases in a
very brave way in order to make
scientific progress science sits at the
confluence of technological and
sociological factors glacier was the
person who commissioned coxwell to build
the mouth to build the balloon and he
did so as part of this broader movement
in the 19th century of moving science
away from the work of the individual
towards the work of large institutions
such as for example the greenwich
observatory but even within that large
framework glacier
and coxwell stand out i think for their
brave
frankly miraculous first return trip
to the stratosphere
science has come a long way since the
1860s and you can learn about some of
our amazing discoveries with brilliant
brilliant is an educational website and
app built around the principle of
learning by doing instead of asking you
to memorize a load of new information
and then regurgitate it on a test
brilliant is about learning topics in
maths science and computer science by
introducing you to a new concept and
then immediately asking you to apply it
and if you get that application right
then great if you don't then you learn
from the experience with no harm done
having worked with brilliant for a long
time by this point i've tried out
several of their expertly written
courses in chemistry and programming and
physics and calculus but i've got
degrees in these areas so i'm probably
not the ideal test subject so i asked my
fiance pixel girl who's a languages
teacher with no scientific training to
try brilliant yeah i gave brilliantly a
girl and i felt that it was really good
in making topics that i've never covered
before understandable like programming
i've always wanted to give it a go but i
never knew where to start made it really
fun and just it was like i really
enjoyed the fact that it was bite-sized
chunks of learning and you felt that
even in five minutes you could learn
something new brilliant is an ideal
companion to classroom learning if
you're in formal education or a fun way
to be introduced to new topics in stem
if like pixelgirl you're a little older
plus a subscription makes for an ideal
present for any ambitious learners in
your life so to get brilliant for
yourself or perhaps support a young
family member through school christmas
is coming up head to brilliant.org simon
clark and the first 200 viewers to do so
will get a sweet 20 discount on an
annual subscription and support this
channel that's brilliant.org simon clark
with thanks to brilliant for sponsoring
this video
the amazing art in this video was made
by the amazing lizzie fierkovsky do
check her out on instagram link below
and check out our previous
collaborations we've made videos on how
the atmosphere changes as you get higher
and higher and on the feasibility of the
planet seen in star trek you can even
buy a poster of lizzie's art in the
former thank you very much for watching
i hope that you liked it if you did
please do pop it a like on youtube and
if you'd like to see more videos like
this then here's some recommended
viewing next thank you again for
watching and i'll see you in the next
one